It was July, 2007, and the dry New Mexico
heat could shrivel your average outsider into
the size of a small keychain.
Melinda and Bailey, two young women dressed
in impeccable costumes of the Harry Potter
characters Luna Lovegood and Hermione Granger,
were getting ready for a momentous event:
The release of Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows, the final installment in the epic
saga of the boy wizard and his quest to defeat
the evil Lord Voldemort.
They, like so many other cosplaying fans,
had driven out to Page 1 Books, an exquisite
bookstore in the very heart of Albuquerque.
It was miles from where the two of them lived,
but more than worth the drive to be part of
the Potterhead fever - long before the series’
author would lose her mind on Twitter and
make the books a lot harder for most people
to enjoy.
Trans rights, by the way.
Bailey and Melinda were counting the seconds
until the bookstore’s doors finally opened,
and they could get the answers to so many
of their burning questions.
Why had Snape killed Dumbledore?
Would Harry, Ron, and Hermoine find and destroy
the last few Horcruxes, allowing them to finally
destroy Lord Voldemort once and for all?
And most importantly of all: Would their ships
sail?
Mel was Harry/Hermoine all the way, but Bailey,
controversially, was all about Ron and Draco.
The two of them couldn’t be more excited
to be part of literary history like this.
The bookstore’s doors opened and, little
by little, the line fed in.
It was worth the long drive in the late evening
and facing the sweltering summer heat.
When the two of them were holding copies of
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows, and
walking back to their car, they knew it had
all been worth it.
Mel thought, this must have been how Jesus
felt when he finished writing the first edition
of the Old Testament.
History, incidentally, had never been Mel’s
strong suit.
Melinda and Bailey set off back to their homes
in the Styx - Bailey was driving; she’d
been kind enough to give Mel a lift, knowing
they were probably their neighborhood’s
biggest Potterheads.
It warmed their hearts to see all this enthusiasm
for the book series they loved so fondly,
seeing so many others in costume, or with
vinyl decals or bumper stickers in their cars
declaring their love of the franchise.
They’d seen Hagrid grabbing a Mocha in Starbucks.
Mad-Eye Moody had been filling up his Buick
at a Gas and Gulp.
And Sirius Black had passed out from heatstroke
and needed to be attended to medically.
With an all-black costume in this kind of
weather, that much was basically inevitable.
As Bailey and Melinda continued their drive,
drawing closer to the witchy wilderness of
Cibola National Forest, they continued sharing
their thoughts, feelings, and predictions
about the book to come.
They couldn’t wait to read it.
Was it even possible for someone to be this
amped about a book?
Their enthusiasm was so great, they didn’t
even notice, on those long, winding back roads,
that another car had started to follow them.
It was 8:15 PM now.
Pitch black.
The kind of darkness where bad things happen.
Eventually, during a lull in the conversation,
Mel turned her eyes up to the rear-view mirror
and spotted the car behind them.
It was a car they’d recognize anywhere:
A turquoise-blue Ford Anglia 105E.
To some, this would be a mostly unrecognizable,
if a little old-fashioned, car, but to Melinda
and Bailey, it could only ever be the enchanted
vehicle of Arthur Weasley - the father of
series mainstay Ron Weasley.
The car, which had become iconic since being
featured in the books and films, was able
to fly and turn invisible, and had gotten
the main characters both into and out of a
variety of amusing scrapes.
Mel told Bailey to take a look, and she couldn’t
help but chuckle in admiration.
Plenty of Harry Potter fans were in town tonight,
and some took it further than others.
At times, Bailey wondered if her three Harry
Potter bumper stickers - reading “My Other
Ride is a Nimbus 2000”, “Save Gas, Take
The Night Bus”, and “All Aboard the Hogwarts
Express”, respectively - were a little excessive.
And then there was whoever this was, whose
intense Harry Potter fandom led them to buy
an authentic Harry Potter car.
Neither Bailey nor Mel could make out the
driver: The car’s windshield was slightly
fogged up.
Strange, seeing as it was such a hot evening
out.
They noticed that the car also must’ve had
broken turn signals, because any time the
car needed to make a turn, the driver’s
arm would slide out the window and make the
appropriate gesture.
The Ford Anglia kept pace with them, following
them at every single turn.
It was only then that they noticed something
a little odd: The car didn’t have a license
plate.
It was almost as though all identifying features
for the car or its driver had been obscured.
Bailey, who was getting a little nervous at
this point, decided to try out a little experiment:
At the next three intersections, she took
three left turns.
It seemed improbable that anyone would actually
intend to take a route that would lead them
in a circle, and yet, the Ford Anglia did
just that.
Bailey’s most frightening suspicion was
confirmed: They were being followed.
She didn’t need to tell Melinda, seeing
as the bad vibes radiating off of the car
were already palpable.
The two assessed their options: They couldn’t
drive home.
After all, the last thing you want is a crazy
person knowing where you live.
Their best bet was to drive to a heavily populated
area - say, the center of Albuquerque during
one of the most highly-anticipated book launches
in recent memory - or better yet, the local
police station.
Whoever was driving this car wouldn’t dare
try anything there.
Bailey and Melinda sped up and took off in
the direction of the city, but to their horror,
the Ford Anglia sped up in kind.
Bailey was pressing the gas pedal down to
the floorboards, and still, the Ford Anglia
gained, its headlights glowing like menacing,
white eyes.
In an instant, it pulled ahead of them, the
driver’s hand emerging once again.
This time, it signaled for them to stop.
The two of them would sooner drive their car
off a cliff than stop for whoever was behind
the murky front window of the Ford Anglia.
As the Ford began to slow, perhaps hoping
to box them in, Bailey pounded on the gas
again and lurched forward, weaving around
the Ford and passing it once more.
Their two copies of Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows were rattling around in the back seats.
Neither Bailey nor Melinda expected this night
to end in a car chase.
But it wouldn’t be the last time their expectations
would be dashed before sunrise.
The two Potterheads were in the lead again,
but it would still be seven or eight miles
before they were officially out of Cibola
National Forest.
Bailey drove as fast as she could; she and
Melinda were frantic messes of terror and
adrenaline now.
But the Ford Anglia kept moving, gaining on
them with every second that passed.
“Go faster, god damn it, faster!”
Melinda screamed in horror.
“I’m going as fast as I can!”
Bailey yelped back.
The car merged into the lane next to them
and sped forwards again.
They were neck and neck now, but it was still
too dark inside the other car to make out
the driver.
Just as Mel was wishing that she could have
a closer look, her wish was granted, in the
worst way possible.
The Ford Anglia abruptly moved to the side
and slammed against them, knocking them off
course with the sudden, shocking blow.
The shock knocked Bailey sideways in the car,
and yanked the steering wheel along with them.
The car veered off the side of the road and
tumbled down the grassy embankment toward
the trees, taking the two unfortunate Potterheads
down with it.
Before they knew it, their fender was wrapped
around the trunk of a ponderosa pine tree.
If it wasn’t for their seatbelts and airbags,
they would have died instantly.
But perhaps, in the end, that would have been
a mercy.
Melinda and Bailey sat up as the airbags deflated
in front of them.
The car was totaled.
As the two of them shakily unbuckled their
belts and climbed out of the car, they were
bathed in the light of the Ford Anglia’s
headlights from above, as though they were
about to be abducted by a UFO’s tractor
beam.
The Ford was just waiting on the road up above
them, its engine rumbling like a low, bestial
growl.
The driver was still obscured behind the foggy
windshield, but their arm was hanging out
of the window once more.
Bailey and Melinda were too frightened and
dazed by the crash to even move as the car
began advancing, with unnatural grace, down
the embankment before them.
It clambered towards them with such uncanny
intent that it seemed almost like it had a
mind of its own, rather than a machine being
piloted by a human being.
Melinda pointed forwards and screamed; she
saw something Baily didn’t.
There was something on the outstretched palm
of the driver’s hand.
She thought it was a tattoo at first, until
she saw it move: Two human eyes were fixed
into the center of the flesh, staring directly
at her - like a crustacean’s eyes on stalks.
Moments later, the car was upon them, and
Melinda’s scream was silenced.
A concerned passerby found Bailey’s abandoned
car crashed in the ditch beside the road the
next morning.
The two women were never found, and two bashed-up
copies of Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
were discovered on the car’s floor, among
all the shards of broken glass, never to be
read.
Some days can be magical, just not in the
ways you would have hoped.
Especially if you run afoul of SCP-3470, a
Euclid-class anomaly somewhat cruelly nicknamed
“Harry Potter’s Revenge.”
Sadly, kidnappings and car accidents aren’t
that uncommon in this strange, scary world
we live in, but at a certain point, the SCP
Foundation’s many field agents detected
a strange pattern in a series of car accidents
near Cibola National Forest in New Mexico.
In all these instances, the cars had been
found crashed, but there were never any bodies.
Eagle-eyed police officers studying the crash
sites also picked up another, more subtle
detail in all these events: The cars had turquoise-blue
paint chips on them, even if the cars themselves
weren’t blue, suggesting the impact of another
car.
Foundation eggheads correlated this with another
strange report they’d received out of New
Mexico.
A young couple had narrowly avoided a dangerous
incident when a car matching the description
of a classic Ford Anglia 105E tried to flag
them down on a dark and lonely road near Cibola
National Forest.
Just like Bailey and Melinda, the duo were
unable to see the driver behind the fogged-up
windshield.
However, when they’d gotten close enough
to see the driver’s hand, they both attested
that it had eyes on its palm - describing
it as similar to the terrifying Pale Man from
the movie Pan’s Labyrinth.
With all of these frightening and clearly
anomalous data points in place, the SCP Foundation
decided it was time to do their due diligence
and go on the hunt for this predatory car.
It wouldn’t be the first time they’d tackled
a sadistic or carnivorous vehicle, and because
of this experience, they weren’t going in
unprepared.
There was, of course, SCP-2086, also known
as the Man-Eating Bus.
These were a species of huge insect-like creatures,
who’d evolved to perfectly mimic your average
city bus in order to lure prey into their
bodies.
Another notable instance was SCP-1386, also
known as the Living Ice Cream Van.
This being is even more mysterious than the
man-eating buses, and boasts a wide range
of abilities, from a hazardous form to a fleshy
appendage somewhat similar to the arm emerging
from SCP-3470.
The jury’s still out on whether either of
these anomalies are in any way directly connected
to SCP-3470, but it gave the SCP Foundation
a few ideas on how exactly to engage, study,
and potentially even contain this new vehicular
slaughterer of man.
Was that last joke kind of a stretch?
Sorry, they can’t all be winners.
As you’ve probably come to expect by this
point when there are still so many unknown
variables involved, the Foundation decided
to fall back on old faithful: Throwing a couple
of D-Classes at it and just seeing what happened.
Two were selected, placed in a standard Foundation
off-road vehicle with dash and rear cams,
and given a variety of equipment - Including
a special semi-automatic assault rifle with
armor-piercing rounds, each one containing
a micro-GPS that would allow the Foundation
to continue tracking SCP-3470 after initial
contact.
And if, in the process of the experiment,
SCP-3470 revealed some frightening new powers,
then a standard vehicle and a pair of D-Classes
weren’t much of a loss.
Once again, another hapless duo were sent
off on the roads in the proximity of Cibola
National Park, though the Foundation hoped
these two would at least end the night accounted
for.
They patrolled the roads, once or twice remarking
on the beauty of the stars up above, while
not much of anything happened.
Command kept close tabs on them back at the
nearest containment site, feeding orders through
earpieces and watching the live video feeds.
As the drive continued, the two D-Classes
finally encountered SCP-3470.
They get closer, at which point SCP-3470 began
its typical pattern of hunting behavior.
It merged onto the road next to the D-Class
vehicle and began to sidle alongside them.
That’s when the two D-Classes realized,
and couldn’t help but remark, that this
looked just like the car from Harry Potter!
Was Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and Wizardry
a new Group of Interest now?
Had Lord Voldemort entered into allegiance
with the Scarlet King?
This was hilarious.
Of course, it didn’t remain all that funny
to the D-Classes for long…
The anomalous Ford Anglia suddenly pulled
up in front of them and ground to an abrupt
halt, forcing the D-Class driving to pound
the brakes, startling both of them.
That’s when the human arm slithered out
from the Anglia’s open window and made the
Stop signal, before twisting around and revealing
the two staring human eyes embedded in its
palm.
The D-Classes started to panic and reverse
away while the car started chasing them at
terrifying speeds.
Foundation Command kept ordering the D-Class
riding shotgun to live up to his title and
blast the vehicle with one of the tracking
bullets, but the driver was so terrified,
he refused to slow down and give his fellow
D-Class a clear shot.
As a result, the armed D-Class released a
flurry of shots, and just got lucky that some
of them happened to strike the car.
This caused it to let out a terrible, pained
shriek, comparable to the squeal of braking
car tires.
SCP-3470 then retreated, allowing the D-Classes
to safely return to base while Command tracked
the Ford Anglia back to its native habitat.
It was time for the next phase of the mission
to begin.
The Foundation brought in Mobile Task Force
Lambda-12, also known as the Pest Controllers
- a group of operatives who specialize in
taking down particularly verminous creatures.
They’d be the ones to track down SCP-3470’s
“nest”, and find out what they were really
up against here.
In order to complete the mission, four members
of the task force were designated for infiltration,
while two others were designated to keep watch
outside.
The infiltrators were given reinforced armor
and a wide selection of weapons and tools,
including a flamethrower, a tranquilizer gun,
a net gun, and a light machine-gun.
SCP-3470’s movements were tracked back to
a cave in Cibola National Forest.
When the infiltration team entered, they saw
track marks with a familiar tire tread on
the floor and walls of the cave, which suggested
a number of frightening things about the anomaly
they were chasing.
As they got deeper into the cave, the air
became intensely hot and humid.
They found scat piles filled with human bones
and a local sheriff’s badge, suggesting
that the car does indeed eat and digest its
prey.
But most terrifying of all, the infiltration
team discovered a number of translucent eggs,
which had small, quadrupedal organisms - assumed
to be the larval stage of SCP-3470 - wriggling
away inside.
They collected some of the eggs and then burned
the rest before turning around to leave.
That’s when they noticed that SCP-3470 was
in the cave mouth, waiting for them.
Except this one wasn’t turquoise, like the
other.
This one was black.
The car began revving aggressively.
After a tense standoff, in which one of the
task force members muttered, “I refuse to
be killed by a goddamn Ford”, the task force
member with the light machine gun opened fire
on the car’s exposed arm.
One of the bullets hit the creature in one
of its hand-eyes, causing it to let out another
pained shriek and retreat from the cave mouth,
allowing the task force to finally escape.
The two who were meant to be on look-out were
never seen again.
SCP-3470 remains at large, with the Pest Controllers
doing whatever they can to track it down and
contain it.
The eggs are also subject to further study.
In the meantime, be careful who you stop for,
because if you end up inside this magical
Ford Anglia, an encounter with the Whomping
Willow is gonna be the least of your worries.
Now go check out “SCP-1958 - Magic Bus”
and “Living Ice Cream Van SCP-1386” for
more villainous vehicles from the world of
the SCP Foundation!